COMMITTEE IN ORDER.
AND NOTICING THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM WILL PROCEED AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE OR WAITING FOR AND
THE AUTHOR.
GIVE HIM.
FIVE MINUTES FROM THE TIME WE
CAN.
I I'LL MAKE MY ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE
WAITING.
SENATOR GLAZER IF YOU'RE
LISTENING YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES
TO GET DOWN HERE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW WILL BE
REPLACING ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROB
BONTA FOR THIS HEARING ONLY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUILAR CURRY
WILL WE ARE PLACING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY FOR THIS
HEARING ONLY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARC
STONE WILL REPLACE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KEVIN MULLIN FOR
THIS HEARING ONLY.
IF ANYTHING
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
IT WOULD TAKE.
FOR ALL OF.
WE HAVE A QUORUM. WILL TAKE
BROAD.
BURKE. HERE.
BRO ALLEN BELOW.
CHIU ANGULAR.
I CAN I CURRY.
MCCARTY MELINDA'S.
STONE QUIRK
HERE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM SENATOR GLAZERS
YOU MAY BEGIN.
YEAH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I
WANNA. SAY PARTICULAR THANKS IN
AND AND.
APPRECIATION TO THE CHAIR AND OF
THE STAFFER HEARING THE BILL WE
HAD SOME PROCESS THAT CHALLENGES
TO OVERCOME AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENTED BILL TO
TODAY. OTHER BEEN NUMBER OF.
AMENDMENT SUGGESTED BY THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION AS WELL AS
YOUR STAFF AT THAT I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT AND ON THAT NOTE WHAT
THEY ARE. AS WE GO THROUGH THE
BILLS BUT IT'S OKAY WITH THE
CHAIR I'D LIKE TO START OFF WITH
THAT CA NINE THAT'S ALRIGHT WITH
TWO BILLS.
OKAY.
RIGHT WELL AS AB MEMBERS ARE
QUITE WHERE WE LIVE IN A
CONSTANT STATE OF EXTREMES IN
REGARD TO OUR WEATHER.
STORK WEATHER PATTERNS HAVE
SHOWN THAT WE'RE GOING BACK AND
FORTH BETWEEN HAVE TIMES OF
HEAVY PRECIPITATION FOLLOWED BY
TIMES OF INTENSE DROUGHT.
AND THE LAST FEW YEARS OF WINTER
HAS REMINDED ALL ALL OF US OF
THAT.
WE NEED TO ADAPT TO THESE
WEATHER PATTERNS AND.
ONE OF THE WAYS TO DO THAT IS
TO CAPTURE AND STORE WATER.
DURING TIMES OF HEAVY
PRECIPITATION AND BY OTHERS
BUSINESSES ARE
OTHER RESIDENTS ETCETERA.
S. CA NINE WOULD ALLOW A
PROPERTY OWNER WHO INSTALLS A
RAINWATER CAPTURE SYSTEM WITHOUT
BILL.
THE DESK CHAIR COUPLE PARAGRAPHS
AND WILL BE DONE.
BUT THE ESSENCE OF THIS IS DO
THAT IF YOU WOULD MAKE THIS
IMPROVEMENT YOUR PROPERTY. THAT
YOUR TAXES WILL GO UP JUST AS WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED FOR THE FIRST
FOR A SEISMIC IMPROVEMENTS AS
WELL AS I.
FOR I.
SOLAR POWER AND THAT'S THE
ESSENCE OF THIS BILL HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HAS RECEIVED
NO NO VOTES ARE ALONG THE WAY IN
THE SENATE THANKS YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ON MORE SYMBOL WHICH I
ENTER INTO HE HAD BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
TRANSPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
AARON EVANS ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES ALSO
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SOMEONE AND. THINK MAN SHALL
MAKE IT QUICK I JUST WANTED TO
SAY I'M CENTER GLAZER THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
THINK WHAT YOUR POINT IS IS
THAT.
HOMEOWNERS SHOULD NOT BE.
.
IN A WAY PUNISHED FOR RECYCLING
BEING.
YOU KNOW CONSERVATION FRIENDLY
TOWARDS THE RARE RESOURCE THAT
DROPS FROM THE SKY EVERY NOW AND
THEN IN CALIFORNIA SO I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL HICKEY.
DARK QUIRK.
I JUST DON'T FEEL FOR TAX
EXPENDITURES.
.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE.
REALLY CLOSE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION LAST RIDE VOTE.
AND THIS ACTUALLY THE BILL AND
AS CA NINE UP BOTH HAPPY PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
TO ADD TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
ORTEGA MOMENTS UP IN
APPROPRIATIONS
TO BE CLEAR.
A CALLER OF.
SP FIVE FIVE EIGHT THE MOST.
S. TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE
BURKE AYE GROW.
ALLEN LOW AYE AYE LOW I TO
ALRIGHT CHU AYE AGYLLA CURRY.
THE KILLER CURRY AYE MCCARTY.
IMMIGRANTS LANDIS AYE STONE
QUIRK.
NOT VOTING FOR.
COMPLETE.
AND OUT THAT IS ON CALL.
IT WOULD.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE CAN
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FOR S. B.
FIFTY.
S. B. AT CA NINE FOR S. B. FIFTY
WITH FIVE OF THE.
WITH THE MOTION FOR OUR.
TO BE ADOPTED.
THE EXTENT OF YOUR DIVERT THEIR
AMENDMENTS TO FIVE FIVE EIGHT
THAT ARE BEFORE YOU THOSE ARE
SUGGESTED BY THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION.
THE REQUESTED TO HAVE A HAVE A
TEN YEAR SUNSET IS AMENDMENTS
THAT WE WOULD NEED TO SUBMIT AN
APPROPRIATIONS SO.
BUT YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU THE
AMENDMENTS THAT. ON DEFINITIONS
THAT CAME FROM THE BORDER
EQUALIZATION THAT WAS ON FIVE
FIVE EIGHT THERE ARE NO
AMENDMENTS TO IT.
THAT IS CORRECT OKAY.
I WAS AWAY FOR THE REMAINING
MEMBERS THAT FILLS ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU ALL LIKE.
PLEASE LET BUCKLEY
.
NOT.
WELL IF THE CALL ON S. B. FIVE
FIFTY.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GROW ALLEN.
CARTY STONE.
STONE AYE MADAM CHAIR THAT BILL
HAS PASSED.
AND THAT MEASURE PASSES WE WILL
SUBSTITUTE.
I'LL JUST CALL HIM FOR.
YES ACCEPTED THE ROLE FOR AT CA
NINE AS CA NINE STONE AYE. THAT
BILL HAS PASSED MANAGER AS CA
NINE HAS PASSED AS WELL
.
MEMBER LONGINGLY SO CALLED.
WITH ONE
ADD ONS TO S. B. FIVE FIVE EIGHT
THE BILL.
ALLEN I.
N. S. C. A. NINE THE
RECOMMENDATION IS THE ADOPTED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BILLS PASSED
ALLEN.
NO ONE ON
REVENUE TAX COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED